all right guys we're going to start the
workshop right now so
hi everyone and thank you for joining us
for the foraging things e workshop today
so this session is for the punch pack
edition of the series so before anything
i'll just introduce myself i'm felicia
from the design singapore council and
i'll just share a little bit about the
program first
before we delve into things proper so
this workshop is part of forager things
an ongoing exhibition by hans tan studio
at the national design center which is
inspired by apocalyptic scenarios where
survivors have to forage from materials
and learn how to build things from
scratch
so this is especially relevant in this
post-pandemic environment where
it really made us question our reliance
on mass manufactured goods
so the meal that you're learning to make
today is actually one of the featured
works and everything in this exhibition
is made from easily accessible and found
components with
downloadable instructions as well so do
drop by the national design center when
you can
to have a look at the other works and
learn how to make them for yourselves
so with that i will hand over the time
to jen and chanel who will be
running the workshop today so jen and
chanel when you're ready
[Music]
okay hello we are jen and chanel and
today we'll be making punch pack
as jen goes into position to prepare for
the workshop
i will share a bit more about the meal
we are making today
okay so this is punch pack and it can be
milled at a cost of a standard letter
it may look unassuming but it actually
disguises a confetti field cavity
we use the stem as a focal point and
with one small push
it will propel a burst of confetti which
will only show you at the end of the
workshop
this meal is suitable for birthdays or
anything that calls for celebration
even christmas which is upcoming without
further ado we'll teach you how to make
it so that you can mail a shower of
happiness to your loved ones
so um before that can all of you
can you do us a favor to ensure that you
have the relevant tools for this
workshop
in front of you you should have a pen a
pair of scissors
a pen knife a metal ruler
and a cutting mat if you have one please
make sure that your pen is the type that
doesn't bleed through
the paper that is writing on it will
also be nice if you have some water
water near you as well because you will
be needing it
to stick the stem it's fine if you don't
have the water now as that's going to be
the last step so you can stick it in
your own time later on
and now let's take a look at our kit
so inside the kit you should find four
pieces of white mountain board
with a rectangular outline in the center
these pieces should be labeled a
and b we will only need one set of a
and b to make punch pack but there's a
spare set just in case we make any
mistakes
so we may set the extras aside
next we'll have four small pieces of
drawing block
also with a rectangular outline in the
middle
this outline is dashed with a one cm gap
on the side
we will also only need one set of this
so you can
set aside the spare piece
next we will have six pieces of colored
paper
one row of double-sided tape
and a second local stamp
so if everyone is okay
sorry we will also have
two pieces of underlog sorry and you
also have a rectangular outline
in the middle which is also dash similar
to the drawing block
we will also only need one of these so
you can set aside the step piece
so if everyone is okay now we can begin
with the pieces of mountbot
this will be the pieces labeled a and b
so for both pieces we are going to cut
out this rectangle in the middle with a
pen knife and ruler
please use a cutting mat or piece of
cardboard underneath so that you don't
cut your table
we'll also recommend that you stand up
so that you're directing your force
downwards onto the materials
and you can begin cutting the non-block
pieces if you haven't started yet please
be careful with this step
so another helpful tip is to not cut the
mountbox all the way through on the
first slice
since the material is quite thick you
can score it first to fill the material
then on the second slice you can cut it
all the way through with confidence
it's also okay if you take more than two
cards to slice through the mount board
you can take your time and don't force
the blade
if you feel that your pen knife is not
slicing well
then the blade is likely to be blunt in
that case you can refresh your blade
it's always safer to cut with a sharper
blade
so
you can use the raised hand function so
that we know that you're done with this
step
please take your time and be careful
look where you're cutting
please remember to use the race hand
function so that we know that you're
done with this step
okay since most of us are done with this
step
let's proceed now we are going to apply
the double-sided tape onto the mount box
for a we are going to apply the
double-sided tape
like this the double-sided
tape should be flush to the edges but it
doesn't have to be perfect
remember to stick them down properly
okay
then once you're done with a we're gonna
do
we're gonna stick the double sided on b
now
and we are going to apply the double
sided tape on the outer edge of the
mount board
like this
the double-sided tape should be flush to
the edges but it doesn't have to be
perfect
you can use the resent function so that
we know that you're done with this step
the double-sided doesn't have to be
perfect but just make sure they are
flush to their respective
corners or edges
please use the race hand function so
that we know that you're done with this
step
okay now let's move on to the drawing
block which are the pieces labeled c
and d so on c and d
there are dashed lines which form a
rectangle in the middle of the drawing
block
this means that we'll be making a series
of small cards separated by one
millimeter gaps there's also a one cm
get on one of the sides
we are going to follow this outline and
perforate the pieces using a pen knife
you can use the pencil markings you can
cut on the pencil markings use it as a
guide
but please make sure to leave that one
cm get uncut
please be careful with this and take
your time to complete
what
please be careful and look at where you
are cutting
and once you're done you can use the red
scan function so that we know that you
are done
please make sure to do this for both
pieces after drawing block c and d
okay for those of you
who are done you can just put your
drawing blocks like this c and d side by
side
if not you can continue doing the
perforation
okay so now we are going to write our
message so we begin
by stick by placing c and d
side by side like this they should look
mirrored and the one cm gaps will be
next to each other in the middle like
this
imagine that the one cm get is the span
of a book
and the recipient will flick open your
message like this
so you can begin writing your message
within the perforated boundaries
on c and d you see as the first page and
then d
as a second page we recommend short
celebratory messages
and a possible message could be happy
birthday
on c and have a blast on d there's no
limit to why you can write
but for us we are going with wishing you
a merry christmas
on c n and a happy new year on d
we will now give you some time to write
your message
another possible message could be
congratulations on c
and you did well on d
we will now apply double-sided tape on
the borders
of c and d like this
the double-sided tape should be flushed
or close to the outer edge
so you can start applying your
double-sided tape now please make sure
that the double-sided does not come into
contact with the perforation
you can use the reset function so that
we know you are done with this step
once again this step doesn't have to be
perfect you can just apply the double
sided tape
close to the outer edge just make sure
that
it's not touching the perforation lines
remember to stick the double sided for
both c and d
so
remember it doesn't have to be perfect
and use the wrist hand function when
you're done with this step
please make sure a double sided is not
touching the perforation
now we are going to start assembling the
pieces we are going to first use
d and mountbot b so make sure you have
b and d with you now we're gonna peel
the double sided tape off d
then after you peel the double sided
tape of d
you can put it on your table sticky side
up
then we are going to take b and paste it
on top of d
try our best to center them
and you should create this cavity where
we are gonna fill with confetti
it doesn't have to be perfect you can
just eyeball it
and try and make sure that it's centered
at this point you should also be able to
see the second page
of your message
and
once you're done sticking this down we
can now locate our colored paper
to make the confetti so we provided six
colors
but we only need three
so you can choose your three colors and
start cutting them up
using scissors
there's no wrong way to do this but
please make sure that your confetti
squares are about five millimeters
half a centimeter big
you can just eyeball this step as well
as you can see we like to first cut them
up into strips
like how jan is showing us
so
and then we're gonna gather these strips
and cut them into squares
you can cut the confetti directly into
the cavity
that you make with d and d
in future if you want to make punch pack
again you can use more than three colors
it's really up to you
you can add personal touch to it to
brighten up the recipient's team
and as you're filling up this cavity
with confetti
it might look like there's too much
confetti but don't worry we can assure
you that
all of it can fit now maybe you can
spread them
around within the cavity so that they
will fit better
and you can use the resin function so
that we know you're done with this step
the confetti doesn't have to be perfect
so just have fun maybe
okay let's move on to the next step
so now we're gonna continue with the
assembly so let's bring in a
and c okay let's start with c
we're going to stick c flip so that the
message
is pointing towards the confetti
make sure that the orientation is
correct and that the edges with the one
cm get are side by side like this
we want the recipient to view your
message as if they are flipping a book
open
so once the orientation is right you can
peel the double sided tape of seed
hello
okay after you've peeled the double
sided of c you try your best to align c
to the center before sticking it down
this part may be tricky but just eyeball
it you'll be okay
don't worry too much about the alignment
and just try your best to center c
before sticking it down
then once you're done with this step you
can start to peel the double sided tape
of b
which is now hidden by the dog by the
by sea but we're just gonna peel it
yes so you will want
to stick c flip so that the message is
pointing towards the confetti
and that the one cm gaps are aligned at
the side
then you try to center it and then you
stick it down
all right can i just check for c
do you stick it to the side
behind a so that the alphabet c and a
can be
is seen on the same side oh no you stick
c on the assembled b and d
you don't uh we don't we will not touch
a first
so it will just be sticking c on top of
the assembled b
and d oh okay on top of
example uh uh b and d okay okay
it should cover the yes it should cover
the confetti
like a dumpling or ravioli okay okay
thanks
and after you're done aligning c to the
center
you can peel the double sided tape off b
which is a piece of mount board
which is already assembled afterwards
you can stick a on top of it
like so
with the double sided tape of a facing
upwards
when you're done
and then if you are done in this step
you can also use the resent function so
that we know that you're done
please make sure that the double sided
tape of a
is facing upwards and can still be seen
after you're done assembling the cut
sorry so for a the double-sided tape is
on top
yes so you don't feel the double-sided
tape of a
you peel the double-sided of b
which is already assembled with your d
and your c yeah then after that you'll
stick a
on top of b yes
so this is going to show you b
and d so this is the assembled b and d
yeah
and then we stick c flipped
so we try to align that and after we
stick this we peel the double sided tape
of d
which is represented by the blue tape
then we stick a on top of the assembled
pieces
oh yes don't worry if you make any
mistakes because this double slider tape
is actually very forgiving
you can peel it slowly and you can redo
the steps if necessary
and remember to use the raise hand
function so that we know that you're
done with this step
okay let's move on so this example card
is going to go into our envelope
so we're almost done now let's set the
cut aside and we're going to start
perforating the envelope
similar to the drawing block pieces
we're going to follow this outline
and create small cuts which are
separated by one millimeter gaps
so make sure your cuts go all the way
through
the envelope such that when you turn it
around you can see the perforation
at the back
so you can cut on the tensile markings
using it as a guide
um
please be careful with this step and
watch where you're cutting
and make sure that your perforations cut
all the way through
so when you turn the envelope around you
can see the markings
this sojourn is showing us that if you
turn the envelope around we can see the
perforations on the other side
then once we are done with that we are
going to peel one of the layers out
such that such that the envelope looks
like this
so as you can see the top layer is
peeled out
but the second layer is left alone
so first you make sure you're on the
correct side of the envelope where there
is no flag
then you can start peeling that top
layer out
and you can use a pen knife to help you
if required
please be careful
starting with the right corner we are
going to slowly and carefully peel this
layer out
and try your best to make sure the tails
are clean
you can take your time to do this step
as well
then once you've reached the site with
the one cm gap
we find that it's helpful to fold it
over first before tearing it off
you can use the raised hand function so
that we know that you're done with this
step
there's a question in the chat do we cut
the non-perforated side if the first
layer of envelope so there's two
perforated sides right we are only going
to peel out one
one of them which is the side where
there is no flap
chain can show again
don't cut out the that flap now yeah
don't cut out the flap
huh don't cut out the the first don't
cut out the flap
make sure you're on the side with the
flat and then we are only going to
peel out that first layer yeah so
everything of the first layer comes down
yes
okay now we can move on and now we're
gonna carefully
insert this assembled card
into the envelope please watch this step
before you continue
so
so please watch this step before you
continue make sure the orientation is
correct
so jen is gonna first peel the double
sided tape of
a
so make sure the one cm gaps are on the
left side
and then we're gonna carefully insert
the assembled card
into the envelope you can try our best
to align the perforations
on the drawing block to the hook
this part may be a bit tricky so take
your time with it
so you should end up with something like
this
now you can try your hand at this jen
will be showing you
a template
putting in
so you can use the racehand function so
that we know that you are done with this
step
if the double sided tape gets stuck on
the flap of the envelope just pull it
apart slowly and gently
and once you're done with this step you
can seal the envelope by peeling the
adhesive strip
you can stick the flap down
and we can get ready to stick our stem
and address
the milk so the finished product should
look something like this
so on the exposed drawing block we're
going to paste our second local stem
and write push heart beneath the stem
remember that um for the stem you need
some water
to add here the stem onto the meal so if
you don't have
water now you can do this at a later
step just make sure that you've left
enough space at the bottom of the
exposed drawing block to write push hard
and after you do this step you can start
addressing
the mail so if you look at a finished
punch pack on screen
we put on top from faith and a bottom to
joy
to the recipient's address
now we'll give you some time to address
the envelope
okay then once you're done with this
step
you're done making punch pack
so if anyone have any questions feel
free to sign up in the chat
if not you can drop this off at your
nearest post box or post office
and mail this out to your friends and
family we are sure they are going to
appreciate the time and effort you put
into making this nail
so now jen is going to pop and show you
what punch pack looks like
wow isn't that amazing
and then your recipient can flip open
the message
to see what you've written for them
okay so for those who are comfortable in
switching on your camera you can switch
on your camera now you know i'm gonna
take
a photo ready
cheese
okay
thank you so this concludes our punch
pack workshop
and it was really enjoyable to teach you
how to make this new
so we hope that through this experience
um
we managed to convince you that analog
mail can be fun to make
and also to receive and thank you for
your time
hi uh i'm colette and lucy uh
today we'll be showing you the process
of making the experimental mail rub
uh i'll be doing the demo and so you
will be going through the steps with you
guys
yep okay bye collette
okay so yeah it's actually a male that
allows the recipient to open it in like
a more unconventional medium which is
water so normally like when you receive
a meal you just like tear it apart but
for this which i use water to open the
milk
so yes before we jump into the making do
make sure that you have
a pen pen knife metal ruler
as well as a cutting mat or any form of
cardboard or like
magazine base so that you don't cut your
table as you're trying to go through the
making process
now we can get started with the home
making process so
first you can take a look at the kits
that you guys have already received
so there should be four sheets of paper
inside
two envelope templates as well as two
embossing templates
so for the ones that are showing on the
screen uh the one on the right should be
the one that you have and the one on the
left we just choose over with markers so
it's a clearer demarcation for you guys
to see
so one set of is actually extra in case
there's some hiccups along the way and
you need to re-cut it so you can just
put the extras at the side
and just have your one envelope template
and one embossing template ready
so there should also be one sheet of
plastic that's already cut out
yep so that is the one that should
also yep that's the plastic sheet there
should also be one stem
in the kit as well which you guys can
use to mail out the mail after you guys
are done
yeah so now we can begin
yes okay so we can first start with the
envelope template is the more squarish
shape of paper that's bigger
so you can actually see solid lines as
well as dotted lines so
firstly you have to use your pen knife
to just cut
along the solid lines and as you can see
it's more of the outline of the paper so
if you're not comfortable with using a
pen knife
you can go ahead and use scissors so for
kids i can see
it's also kids friendly but you can just
try and see if the kids can go ahead and
use the scissors
to go about it yes okay
yep so just go over slowly don't need to
rush this process
so as you can see if you want to
personalize your mail or make it into
any other shapes you can just
follow the two rectangular format in the
shape that you want and then just add a
one cm flap along the edge of one side
so that way you can actually just make a
personalized envelope of any size that
you want
if you do want to replicate this mail in
the future
and sometimes it's easier if you stand
up to cut it as well so like your body
weight can help you
move the pen knife smoothly if you want
yeah so do use the raisen function when
you're done so like we can have a rough
gauge
to see if we can move on
so collects actually done so that's how
it should look like at the end
okay so yeah so now we'll just move on
first
okay so for the next step you'll see the
dotted lines along the edges
so just try to fold these lines yeah so
some ways to make sure that the lines
are folded cleanly so you can do a light
scoring
like with like the back of your pen on
the back of your pen knife
just make sure that it's not like a
sharp blade it's just like a sharp edge
like it's just an edge or something so
you can just score it to make like a
little indent
either that or you can just like fold it
against the edge of your pen knife uh on
the edge of your ruler like what
collette is doing
yeah so this can ensure like a more
clean fold as you go about
it yeah so you can just repeat this step
for all four sides of the dotted lines
that you're going about doing these
steps right it's also good to kind of
think about what messages
you guys might want to write on this
mail as well
so after you're done with the folding do
use the raised hand button as well to
help
indicate oh wait i have to
look yeah okay yeah use the right hand
button as well
to indicate if you're done
okay yeah so now that the cutting and
folding is done
i see most of you your hands are raised
okay
so you can just put this whole sheet
aside first yeah just
put it aside yes okay so next we can
move on to the embossing template
this is actually the shriek that has a
little shaded
rectangular box in the center yes
so that's the one yeah
so now just get out your pen knife again
so this step might be a bit hard to use
the scissors so pen knife will probably
be necessary so just
cut along the parameter of the shaded
rectangle
yes
so this sheet of embossing template is
actually made from
the same material as the envelope
template but just fold it four times
so which is why it's significantly
thicker when you feel the material
so however if you don't have like a big
sheet of paper that you can afford to
fold you can
always just make this embossing template
using
four separate sheets of paper and you
can just glue them on top of each other
to create this kind of thickness
yes yeah apart from that just
the paper is a bit thicker so it might
be a little bit harder to cut through
so just slowly go over it a few times
there's no rush
yep yeah and if it helps you
can stand out to try and do it so that
you can use your body weight for this
as well
so same as the envelope template this
embossing template can
also be easily personalized you want to
make the space a bit bigger
you want to make the space a bit longer
you can just change the size
of this shaded rectangle and cut out
that shape
accordingly and then you can have your
own personalized
template for embossing yep so
this embossing template will actually be
used to create the indentation to
demarcate the area
in which you write your messages yes
yeah so when you're done do use the
raise hand function
okay i see you guys are slowly getting
there yeah okay
looks good okay
so now there's a bit more assembly
involved
so if you guys get any confused at these
steps do just
unmute your mic sound out to us yeah so
next you actually need to take
your embossing template and place it
over
your envelope template so you can watch
colette and what she's doing
right now
yes as you can see her folds are facing
upwards and her
embossing template is sitting inside the
envelope template nicely
yes so now you can just fold down the
top flap
like what colette is doing yes
no need to worry about what like the
side one cm flaps are doing they can
just be there
yeah so just make sure that it's aligned
properly and fold down
yes and then now you can feel the
rectangle you should be able to feel
like this kind of line at the center
which is caused by the indentation
the embossing template which you cut a
hole through just now
yeah so now we're gonna try and make an
indentation using
this template so you can use the back of
a pen
which is rounded or you can use like the
the glue that we provided that's a bit
but it'll be a bit thicker so just try
and tilt it a bit so use
an edge to go over the line inside
yes can watch collab first before you
start doing it
so she's just slowly going over the
edges
yes so just make sure that since it's an
embossing we're not
cutting or tearing through the paper so
do go over it really slowly first to
make sure that there's some sort of
marking before you use
a bit more string yes because if you
just go on really hard it tends to tear
so just try and go over it slowly and a
few times
and you should be able to see that the
edges are slightly rounded
because your pen is rounded so you won't
be able to get that clean
sharp edge which is good yes because
we're looking for like this slightly
rounded edge
yes
yep so do use the raised hand button as
well when you're done or if you have any
questions
do just on your mic and let us know
so nice you can just open open your
envelope
yes okay and then remove the embossing
time you know
don't remove the embossing template
sorry leave the embossing template there
and use that embossing template as a
guide to
as a space to where you can write your
messages yes
so your message should fit nicely within
this rectangular box
yes
yeah so just make sure that the edges
are aligned to the sheet before you
start writing to make sure that
the boundary is correct and aligned to
the embossing that you made earlier
yeah so just use your pen to write the
message within the boundary
uh do make sure that you're using a pen
that doesn't bleed through the paper
so if you want to do some form of
testing you can always just write on the
off cuts first
to see if like it's going through to the
back and if that's okay then you can
just
go ahead and use that pen yes
yeah a faint line will be fine yeah just
don't use like
a very thick or wet marker of sorts
yeah so rat actually allows like a slow
review
which makes it a good medium to
reconcile with your loved ones through
short but sincere apology messages
of course you can also shake things up
by changing the mood of the male by
using different colored paper or by
changing the size and shape of the mail
that we mentioned before earlier
so it's really up to your imagination so
during our test
we have also used this mail to write
cute confession letters
or even like well wishes for the
holidays and
yeah color will be showing you some
variations
that we did at the end
yes colette will be showing you the
variations at the end
so yes this is just a simple message
that could have written
you can go ahead and think of your own
messages to write
and when you're done with writing the
messages can just use our hands up
button and let
us know yes so we'll show you the demos
at the very end
on some of the iterations that we did
yes
uh nicole you asked if you can write in
pencil yes we can
you can write in pencil there's no
problem with that yeah
okay so now we'll move on to sealing
the envelopes yes no need to move on to
before we seal the envelopes there's one
more step that we need to do which is
the plastic sheet
yes so we also provided you with
a piece of plastic the plastic we've
provided for you actually has
a smoother side and a rougher side so
just feel the plastic a little bit
and make sure that the smooth side is up
and facing you
before you put it down
yeah so for the plastic sheet that we
provided we actually pre-cut it for you
guys
so when you guys want to make this by
yourself just make sure that the length
and width of the plastic sheet itself is
just like
0.1 cm smaller than your actual
rectangular paper so that make sure when
you close the flat the
sheet doesn't fold up so it fits nicely
along the edge
and if you do want to make it at home
and you don't have access to like this
kind of plastic material you can always
use
like plastic folders plastic bags or
anything that's just
transparent yeah so that's up to you to
source around as well
so after that we just have to seal the
envelope
so you see the flaps at the side those
1cm flaps just use the glue
that we've provided just apply glue on
before the flaps in first and you apply
the glue at the outside of the cell
oh yeah this is doing yes so just
yes apply the glue along with this do
apply a generous amount as these will
help ensure that the glue
the envelope will be tightly sealed yes
so if you're worried about how the
ceiling would be
after you close the envelope you can
always just like put it underneath a
stack of
books so that there's some form of
weight to press it down
i can sit on it if you want that's
perfectly okay as well just make sure
you don't bend it yeah so
give it a good press along the edge to
make sure that it's
tightly sealed yes
when you're done with that do give a
hands up as well so that we'll know when
to proceed
so now the main mail itself is done but
we'll just have to write some words and
some form of instructions for a
recipient so that they know what to do
when they receive this mail
so along the indentation that you have
already made
do write the words water plus wrap
but you can try and space it out the
words or try and centralize it
like what colette likes to do is she
writes the plus in the center first
before she writes water and then rub it
aside so like it helps centralize the
words
but yeah it's purely up to you guys as
well how you want to do this
it's just an instruction for your
recipient on what they can do after they
receive your
mail yep
so after that is done
you can just flip the envelope around
yes okay yes okay so now you can
apply your stems at the top right hand
corner
and you can write the name and address
of the person you want to
send it to as well
for the steps you can just get the local
30 cent
stamps that are really standard that you
can buy from
the postal office as well as the
machines that you can see around
yeah so after you guys are done you can
always just
give a hands up or if you guys want to
save the writing to a later time or
paste the stamp later that's perfectly
fine as well
yes just so while you guys are still
doing the steps uh
colette will be preparing to show you
some demonstrations later
yes so we'll show you guys some of the
past trials that we did as well as how
your recipient will be opening the mail
later when they do receive it
yes yep okay looks good
okay so yes i'll be doing some
demonstrations
yes so this is how your recipient will
be opening the mail after they see the
instruction they can just get a bit of
water
and yeah so the indentation actually
acts as a
demarcation of where the use
the male yes and after rubbing they'll
be able to
reveal the message at the underneath
side of it
so as you can see it's like a slow
process
and we want to see
like water as a medium can bring about a
different emotion when it comes to
opening milk as compared to
the conventional like bearing kind of
method
yeah so the plastic sheet inside
actually acts as
a surface that will prevent the water
from
going through so you only tear the top
layer but not the bottom so your message
will still be able to be seen
yes so this will be the final state of
how the mail will be
after your recipient opens the mail yes
okay so due to the upcoming festive
christmas seasons we've like should we
also make like some iterations
yes so this is another one that we made
so we actually used a green sheet of
paper inside
instead of the white so we just layer a
piece of colored paper inside and write
the message of white
so when we rub it it actually has like
this little white
paper strap that kind of looks like snow
in a sense
yeah so like that's another variation of
what you can make
yes yep that's also another example that
we've made
yeah so these are just some variations
and how the mail will look like when you
open it with water yes
so if you guys have any questions do
feel free to
unmute your mic yes and sound out to us
and yep that is all from
us regarding how to make this meal yes
if there are no questions we'll
we need you guys to on your cameras yes
so that we can oh sorry uh yes we all
need to yeah on your cameras to take
like a good screenshot photo of the
session
yes okay
colette will be joining us
okay three two two one
okay oh actually those those are not
holding out their mails can you like
just hold up your mail first to see also
yes i can take another photo thank you
okay one two three
yay thank you so much we hope you guys
have fun
and yes do try out to make all the other
meals as well along the way
all right hi everyone hello
uh all right
we're deborah and nathaniel and we're
going to be going
like to go through how to make whiteout
so ned over here is going to be the
demonstrator for today
so while he gets ready at the other
camera if you're comfortable
could everyone like turn on their
cameras
okay so uh so this is the mail that
you're going to be making today
it's kind of like a compact snow globe
with the salt
falling like snow to uncover the message
within
yeah just checking
sorry about like checking on the camera
right now
okay yeah so
yes okay now it's on screen this is the
mail that we're going to be making today
and so it kind of like reveals the
message in between
when you pour and shake it out so it
makes it really great for
christmas well wishes so
[Music]
before we go and start to go through
what's in the kit
make sure you have your pen knife
cutting mat and scissors with you
and if you don't already have it you
kind of have like a few seconds to get
it now
so now we'll be going through the
contents in the kit inside the kit
there is sufficient material for you to
make two sets but we'll just be making
one for now from the kit you can take
out your two sheets of tracing paper
as shown a single sheet of black
cardstock with
nothing on it
one black card stock with merry
christmas cut out from it
all right the small white card like
mounting board in your packet
like
one packet of salt
a roll of double sided tape and glue
stick
yep oh okay
okay so first thing first we're gonna
take the black cardstock with merry
christmas
cut out from it so flip the cardstock
such that the letters facing you are in
reverse and place it on the table
so using the glue stick spread an even
layer of glue on the side of the
cardstock
so a tip here would be to go around the
letters first
like like such and then
you can use the glue stick to dab on the
smaller bits in between the letters
so yeah you can like follow that and
like dab it on like the letters
so this make sure this ensures that the
glue doesn't clump onto
the edge of the letters and just make
sure that the entire surface
is covered
okay so once you're done with like
applying the glue
take the black the plain black piece of
cardstock
and stick it onto the merry christmas
card so
you can take your blank sheet
and align the edges to like
and stick it on yeah
so you can use your hands to like press
them together tightly
and especially around the letters so you
can squeeze and pinch it
as such
so once you're done with that you can
raise your hand on zoom to let us know
you're done
yep
okay
okay so
uh all right seems like most people are
done we'll be
letting it dry while we work on the next
step so
you can put it aside and like leave it
to dry
now take one sheet of tracing paper and
lay on the table
take your double sided tape and stick it
along the edges of the tracing paper
so note that it's like super important
to cover the edges completely
so we recommend they stick each double
sided
tape from corner to corner and it's okay
if like the tape's over that
so
yeah you can use like either your pen
knife or scissors to like cut off the
edges of the double side the excess
double-sided tape
uh
okay so
once you're done with that you can do
that the same with the black cardstock
so just now we have
the card stock with the merry christmas
good so you turn it around to the side
without the letters on it
and then do the same by sticking the
double sided tape along the edges of
this black card stock
so again to make sure that the salt
doesn't stick
we need to make sure the edges are
covered completely so stick each double
sided tape
from corner to corner
okay uh so for the person who just
joined
uh we're making white out and we are at
the set where
uh with kind of like we've already like
gone through like sticking the merry
christmas
card onto the black card stock so if you
would like to you can
like do that step first and follow along
for the other sets
[Music]
sure
um
okay so uh
but now we're gonna be assembling all it
all together
so so from the black cardstock you can
peel off the backings of the
double-sided tape
so it might be a little tricky because
of like the tapes that you overlap
so we we recommend that you peel the
double-sided tape that's
underneath first so it's like a little
easier to stick the rest later
[Music]
so
once you're done peeling like the
double-sided tape from the black
cardstock
you can take your tracing paper with
double-sided tape and put it on the
table
like with the double-sided tape facing
up
yeah so
yeah okay we can easier
but okay so
so make sure that the double-sided tape
is facing up
and if you want you can peel the like
double-sided tape out that
too as well
okay so now with like all the backings
removed
you can take the black cardstock and
center it on top of the tracing paper
yeah so flip it so it's this double
sided tape is facing down
and center it
yeah so like you can like take your time
with this and like
stick it down
so once you're done with this step you
can like raise your hand on zoom
sorry can you um we repeat the step
like oh which side
um do we put the black card down on
the side that has the double sided tape
or the other side
so it's the side with the double-sided
tape okay on the chasing paper
yeah so can we leave the double-sided
tape on first and then center it and
then take off the double thread
yeah you can do that
okay seems like everyone's like done as
well
here so where now we're gonna be like
adding the salt
so now take your ziploc bag of salt
and carefully pour out the salt across
the lettuce of the black cardstock
so you need to be like super careful not
to spill any of like
the salt onto the double-sided tape yeah
so uh so now just open your ziploc bag
saw and
pour it across the letters
so and yeah
if you're like kind of afraid of like
the salt falling onto the double-sided
tape you can use your like
a small white card to like like shield
it away
and like push the salt into the middle
right into the letters
yeah so you can pour all the salt in
your bag onto the card
so if you're once you're done with that
step you can also raise your hand on
zoom
so
hmm
okay so
at this point we're we're almost there
and this next step is super important
and we like everyone to like watch first
before you go ahead
so now take your second sheet of tracing
paper
and align it to the bottom edge of the
package
so yeah
align it and then
gently place it down on the like
on your package like that
and stick the bottom edge first
yeah okay so
next like to gently like like squeeze
like the rest of the pack
like gently pat it down like across each
edge
all the edges and use your fingers to
like smoothen
and stick the tracing paper across all
the edges
yeah so
[Music]
once you kind of like tap it down and
like it's quite subtle you can also use
your like white
the small white card to like smooth out
all the
air bubbles and stick it down tightly
so once you're done you can also raise
your hand
and at this point it's
pretty much finished yeah
you can try
you can try playing with it now as well
and just to like season it and like make
sure like all the
all the edges are like sealed
like just a reminder if like you're done
with this part you can like raise your
hands on soon to let us know
and they'll still be like kind of like
any finishes that
to personalize your message even further
yeah
okay
so
okay so
at this point like your meal is pretty
much
finished and if there are like any
sticky edges that you can feel
along the edge of the of that meal you
can trim it
use your like pen knife to trim it off
just
like make sure that you don't trim off
all the like double-sided tape along the
edge
so it can be just a very slight pen
knife yeah
like cut
and
if you want you could also like use your
pen knife to like round out the edges
but this is like completely optional
as well or like scissors also with this
like
easier
okay and
if you want to send the mail like to
send it like the mail out
you can turn it over to the non-south
side
and write your recipient's address on
on there
so like you can think of like who you
would like to send it to and write that
address up down
in the middle portion
and you can also use the stamp that
we've also placed
in the back in the kit and stick it at
the top right corner
yep and
you can trim off the edges of your
scissors again
okay
and yep it's this is
whiteout like finish so um actually
like with the second kit we you can have
a go at creating your own message with
the extra set of materials we've
provided
in the back so like you'll notice
there's like two pieces
of plain black card stock so on one of
them
actually you can you can just trace and
cut out a design
on one of the black pieces of cardstock
and repeat the making process
that we've shown you today yeah
and it can be very simple like how like
a christmas tree or something
and just to like cut it out really fast
all right
right so
yeah so uh that's it from us today uh we
hope you had fun
making your own meal and we hope you'll
like bring joy to the people that you
send it to
uh last thing we'd like to do is to take
a group photo with everyone here
in the like call so if
you guys wouldn't mind do like turn on
your camera and hold up your finished
mail
so you can take a screenshot yeah
yeah thanks again once again for like
taking the time to come to the workshop
okay so this is the final form of
kingdom so i'll light it up for you to
see
how it looks like later on
so it looks like
okay i'll put this aside and we will
show you guys later
okay so um firstly you'll be able to
find all these materials
in a packaged meal to you so you'll be
able to have your river to
receive like two two sets of all these
okay so um okay so you'll see like
this square piece of paper that is
marked up by dotted and solid lines
as well as one that is a clean piece of
square paper and this pre-cut
piece of paper that is used for your box
later on
as well as two packets of wax for
melting
and a packet of ziploc bag with two week
bits inside as well as a double-sided
tape
and a metal spoon
so you have to prepare um a pen
preferably 4.10 as well as a
pen knife and a ruler for cutting
okay so when everyone is ready could you
press on the
waist hand function so we know when to
begin
okay we'll start now so firstly you take
this square piece of paper
that's marked up by the dotted and solid
lines
and then you take um your ballpoint pen
and
esteem roughly estimate the center of
this piece of paper
and poke a hole through it
if your pen is unable unable to put a
hole through
you can use a pen knife as well
once you are done you can write um your
desired message that's marked up
within the dotted lines as marked out on
the square piece of paper
so kindle is made for like birthday
messages but
due to like the as we are nearing the
christmas season we will also recommend
you to write more intimate messages or
short poems to your loved ones so you
can have fun and write anything that you
want
okay so um next we will be
cutting um we will be cutting out like
all these solid
solid as marked up by the solid line so
all these four corners
one two three and four so we cut
cut out a small square piece of paper
using our pen knife and ruler
so
this is how it's supposed to look like
after you are done
okay so for those who are done um you
retract
your pen knife and you use the tip to
lightly score the dotted lines
so you don't cut it by just go along the
lines that's marked up by the dotted
lines
on all four sides
so
okay and after scoring you fold you fold
the four corners inwards towards where
your message
is to form a container
so
okay so next we'll take this long strip
of paper
and we'll apply double sided tape from
one end to the other end
so
okay so after you're done you peel off
the backing of the double-sided tape
and then before you start could everyone
just pay attention to what i'm doing
first so
with the long strip of paper you apply
you stick double-sided tape
from one end of the from the from this
end of the box
and then you go around it to form the
shape of a container
and making sure that um you seal it very
tightly this is to prevent the wax from
spilling out later when we pour it in
and when you have reached the end off
when you have reached where you started
you just overlapped
okay so after that you take you take out
one piece of wig from the ziplock bag
and then you poke it halfway through the
hole which you have created previously
so it should only go through like
halfway
this is the back and this is the front
and then after that when you turn to the
back you push the weight
downwards towards the container and you
can
rest it you can press it against the
table such that um
it's made such that like you'll be
pressed
onto the base
and then after that take double sided
tape and
stick it onto the base of the container
okay so next we take this square piece
of paper
and we apply double sided tape along the
edges of it
on all four sides
okay so after you're done applying peel
off the backing
and stick it onto the back of
your can of the container but also
remember to remove the double sided tape
that's attached to the
wig
so make sure to press it down tightly so
that the wick
or the wax doesn't leak later on
okay while you are still doing our pass
this time to select we'll be going
through the second half of the tutorial
hi so i'll be going through the second
half of the tutorial
at this point you should have a
container that looks like this
when you reach this point you can use
the waist hand function to indicate that
you're video
ready to move on to the next step
okay so for the next step we will need
the metal spoon
and two packets of wax we have two
packets because we split the amount the
exact amount of wax needed into two so
that's more manageable
and for this next step before we begin i
want you to look up at the screen to
watch how
it will play out before you try on your
own
so for this part we'll be melting the
wax so we recommend that you do it over
a stove but just for demonstration i'll
be using a windproof lighter
but later when you when you melt it over
a stove just be careful that
there are no flammable objects nearby
and we also recommend that
the adults take over this step
so first you empty one packet of wax
one packet of wax into the metal spoon
so i'll just demonstrate first you can
try later
so you empty one packet of wax into the
metal spoon
and as you're melting it
all of it should turn completely
transparent
so there shouldn't be any white pieces
of wax left
this will take a while
if you can see in the camera it should
be slowly thinning the transparent
liquid
and when everything is melted you can
take the container that you made earlier
and just slowly gently pour it in
so you can tilt the container a little
bit to make sure that all of the liquid
reaches the edges
and we'll repeat the exact same thing
for the second step for the second
packet of wax
but this time for the second packet it
will be even more important to make sure
that everything reaches the edges so
that you have a smooth surface at the
top
you can try it now
you might want to unmute yourself first
so that you can easily ask any questions
later while you're doing the melting
process
just let me know
what
foreign
uh
let it cool but be careful not to tilt
it too much okay so that the wax won't
spill out
will see it slowly start to become
opaque but even as it becomes opaque the
inside is most definitely still liquid
so try not to it will take a few minutes
to harden
i think while mounting your wax you can
think of who you want to send this to
because you'll be writing that name and
address later
just be careful okay not not to tilt it
too much while it's hardening
so that the surface will harden nice and
smooth
okay we can lift the candle aside now to
let it continue hardening
and we can move on to the next step so
for the next step you'll need the box
template which is this
piece
the you'll be able to see that there are
lines being drawn already
so the lines should be facing up facing
you
and we can fold it inwards you can fold
according to all the lines drawn and
four
try to make it a nice day a nice day
so the line should be on the inside
after you're done folding
you can use the raise hand function
after you're done with this step also
okay so for the next step we'll flip
this over to this side
and you can see that this for the square
that is connected to all of the flaps
we'll be writing our name and our
recipient's name and address on that
side so in this square write it in the
bottom half
because we need the top half for the
stem
if you haven't thought of someone and
send it to you don't have to write it
now we can write it later after before
the box just that it would be easier to
write it before before the box
if you don't have this step you can
always you can use the resent function
also
so you know when to move on
so on the same side you will see that
there are three sections that are being
shaded
should be one two and this long one over
here
so we'll be sticking double-sided tape
on on the entire length of each section
so only on the shaded areas
when you're done sticking double-sided
tape we can use the waist raise hand
function again
and then i'll demonstrate the next step
okay so for the next step i need you to
um watch how i
fold your box first before you try on
your own
so we'll just remove all the double
sided tape first
and okay so i need you to watch this
part
so we have um two small flaps and one
long one
we'll be folding the we'll be sticking
the small ones first
so as you can see we want to stick um
each
double sided tape section as close to
the
edge as possible like that
let me take it down aligning it to the
edge so that's the first small flat
and for the second one it will be
aligned to the other end
and for the long one so now it should
look like this
and for the longer one it will be
aligned as well it should be at the
exact length already
so you just stick it nicely and make
sure that everything is stuck around
and in the end your box should look like
that
and this hole is so that your recipient
can push out the kindle
when they receive it so you're gonna
push it out easily without having to
struggle
you guys can try it now if you have any
problems just let me know
and once your box is complete you can
use the resin function again
and now you can check on your kindle it
should be completely harder now
you will know because it will be quite
cool to the touch and it will be a
smooth
opaque white surface
you can test it it should be quite hard
now
and you can sort it into your box
just yep just like that and
you can close the flap
and once you're done with that you can
take the stem that has been provided in
your kit
and stick it onto the top half right
above the name and address that you have
written
and it should look like that
and just like that it will be ready to
be posted
we now be showing you the finished
kindle
the one that finishes like a lighter at
the start
so when your recipient receives it and
lights it up and waits for it to melt it
should look like that so they can see
exactly what's written beneath the
liquid surface liquid wax surface and
if and when they blow it out
it will slowly become opaque as it cools
and hardens again
and that's the end of our kinder
tutorial if you
if you don't mind we would you could you
all over on your cameras and
we'll take a good photo now if you don't
want to show your face it's okay you can
show your finished kindle in the edit
in front of the camera
okay one two
three sorry sorry give me a moment
thank you thank you
i hope hope you guys had fun making it
and remember if you want to make more
kindles in the future
you need a 60 cent non-standard meal
stem because
kinder is too small to be considered
standard male 1
and that's all for today merry christmas
merry christmas now
pass the time back to dsg
right thank you so much felicia and
celeste thanks for teaching us how to
make kindle
now kindle is just one of 16 of these
experimental mails that you will find at
the
forager things exhibition so do come
down to the national
design center to check out the
exhibition it runs daily
from now until 6 of february next year
and
it's open 9 a.m to 9 p.m every day
before you go we really appreciate it if
you could complete a simple survey for
this workshop to help us improve
on our future programs you can do so by
scanning the qr code you see on the left
and if you like to find out more about
the various upcoming programs that the
national design center has lined up
under our december theme of a future by
design
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right now
with that we will officially end today's
session and thank you once again to
felicia and celeste and to all of you
for spending your afternoon with us
have a great rest of the day ahead bye